watch how much uh motion there is in my
wrists and in my hands my fingers
okay so w you see thumbs thumbs Le
thumbs Le they Le the whole
[Music]
way thumbs Le thumbs Le
boom right
here not Palms
leaving push thumbs
Le just keep doing the EM spirals out it
[Music]
goes doesn't matter how you do it let's
say you're here like that I just got to
get out then my thumbs
leap go this way still going to do it
bus leave
and we spiral here's your our spiral can
you see
[Music]
it then resp spiral boom
spiral oh thumbs lead boom pinky leads
do you see it Pinky
leads
thumb leaves boom pinky
leaves down up in
out okay try it
again finish the
finish don't don't go right from here
with your
thumbs and then
around finish the
movement thumbs then down then
round thumbs till it's off then down
then
around
and he's I'm not interested in him
throwing okay uh these these these
movements that I'm doing this is what I
want so I have my water hand right and
my fire hand up top you see I'm just
doing them at the same
time
two don't if you pay attention you see
how my hands come out you see they're
coming out there's no point doing that
if I was just trying to throw him okay
so the same way here you're going to be
on top you see I'm on top but that this
is not it there's still more through the
spiral do you see then I come
down w't finish it
Bo just concentrically as I do that I'll
be stuck I'm stuck I you can't push
forward you can't push
forward but I'm interested in moving
this energy with those
pns okay try it again so you can do it
standing too if or people are hurt and
they can't do see what was of it's all
the same so I come down around just make
sure that this this energy goes down
okay it's got to go down but it's got to
go in too because now we coming up and
out okay so boom
[Music]
down
this not here
okay finish
the
[Music]
okay try it